Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Reinforcement learning is an awesome algorithm
that is able to play computer games, navigate
helicopters, hit a baseball, or even defeat
Go champions when combined together with a
neural network and Monte Carlo tree search.
It is a quite general algorithm that is able
to take on a variety of difficult problems
that involve observing an environment and
coming up with a series of actions to maximize
a score.
In a previous episode, we had a look at DeepMind's
algorithm where a set of movement actions
had to be chosen to navigate in a difficult
3D environment efficiently.
The score to be maximized was the distance
measured from the starting point, the further
our character went, the higher score it was
given, and it has successfully learned the
concept of locomotion.
Really cool!
A prerequisite for a reinforcement learner
to work properly is that it has to be given
informative reward signals.
For instance, if we go to a written exam,
as an output, we would like to get a detailed
breakdown of the number of points we got for
each problem.
This way, we know where we did well and which
kinds of problems need some more work.
However, imagine having a really careless
teacher who never tells us the points, but
would only tell us whether we have failed
of passed.
No explanation, no points for individual tasks,
no telling whether we failed by a lot or just
by a tiny bit.
Nothing.
First attempt, we failed.
Next time, we failed again.
And again and again and again.
Now this would be a dreadful learning experience
because we would have absolutely no idea what
to improve.
Clearly, this teacher would have to be fired.
However, when formulating a reinforcement
learning problem, instead of using more informative
scores, it is much easier to just tell whether
the algorithm was successful or not.
It is very convenient for us to be this careless
teacher.
Otherwise, what score would make sense for
a helicopter control problem when we almost
crash into a tree?
This part is called reward engineering and
the main issue is that we have to adapt the
problem to the algorithm, where the best would
be if the algorithm would adapt to the problem.
This has been a long-standing problem in reinforcement
learning research, and a potential solution
would open up the possibility of solving even
harder and more interesting problems with
learning algorithms.
And this is exactly the what researchers at
OpenAI try to solve by introducing Hindsight
Experience Replay, HER, or her in short.
Very apt.
This algorithm takes on problems where the
scores are binary, which means that it either
passed or failed the prescribed task.
A classic careless teacher scenario.
And these rewards are not only binary, but
very sparse as well, which further exacerbates
the difficulty of the problem.
In the video, you can see a comparison with
a previous algorithm with and without the
HER extension.
The higher the number of epochs you see above,
the longer the algorithm was able to train.
The incredible thing here is that it is able
to achieve a goal even if it had never been
able to reach it during training.
The key idea is that we can learn just as
much from undesirable outcomes as from desirable
ones.
Let me quote the authors.
Imagine that you are learning how to play
hockey and are trying to shoot a puck into
a net.
You hit the puck but it misses the net on
the right side.
The conclusion drawn by a standard reinforcement
learning algorithm in such a situation would
be that the performed sequence of actions
does not lead to a successful shot, and little
(if anything) would be learned.
It is however possible to draw another conclusion,
namely that this sequence of actions would
be successful if the net had been placed further
to the right.
They have achieved this by storing and replaying
previous experiences with different potential
goals.
As always, the details are available in the
paper, make sure to have a look.
Now, it is always good to test things out
whether the whole system works well in software,
however, its usefulness has been demonstrated
by deploying it on a real robot arm.
You can see the goal written on the screen
alongside with the results.
A really cool piece of work that can potentially
open up new ways of thinking about reinforcement
learning.
After all, it's great to have learning algorithms
that are so good, they can solve problems
that we formulate in such a lazy way that
we'd have to be fired.
And here's a quick question: do you think
8 of these videos a month is worth a dollar?
If you have enjoyed this episode and your
answer is yes, please consider supporting
us on Patreon.
Details are available in the video description.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!